no my tip decisions is usually all
across the board if they're just chill
it's 18 percent
if I like them 25 if I feel like I want
to do a sexual favor to them but I'm not
sure
[Music]
all right we're gonna have to get to the
bottom of this and see who
who in the right and let me get my
detective hat on good all right cool
let's go paraphernalia you got another
one I got a couple you guys want oh I
want something
this isn't even that kind of it's not
that deep
here's some detective hacks I picture
like the police commissioner coming into
the department okay I've got a case and
everyone just sleeps
I got that's a that's a Biden hat we got
a trump map
who's gonna wear a trump hat somebody
wear a trump hat this is hot what's that
one uh theme where like everyone dances
at the same time a what oh a flash mob
yeah Adventure like the police
combination Avenue case and everyone
just does a flash moment too but it gets
happy yeah she got like three hats on
you're about to see how like completely
Overkill that was here's the case okay
and this is still within um I guess
within litigation they haven't figured
it out yet
a guy in Pennsylvania
dines at a cafe oh [ __ ] he then receives
his bill for thirteen dollars nice okay
okay he feels charitable on this day and
he decides to tip three thousand dollars
whoa what the [ __ ] and it clearly says
three zero zero zero is it three zero
dot zero zero no dot no Dot and he even
admitted that oh like he was uh inspired
by this thing that was going around
called tips for Jesus
so uh there was some real power behind
him no commas either just three and then
just three zeros lots of room for a
comma I might wait is it just like a
regular dude or is he like an influencer
guy because I've seen people do this on
Mr Beast I think got really big doing it
too just a regular guy so he leaves that
three thousand dollar tip she adds to it
the server of course is like
obviously elated and she's like oh my
God thank you so much and the restaurant
goes and they don't take any of it and
they give it all to her that's wow
some days later
the payment is under dispute because the
guy regrets doing it
sorry Jesus
he thought he won the lottery or some
[ __ ] he's like I'm feeling generous
today uh yeah so at this oh I don't even
have three thousand dollars to give why
did I do that wait this is like that
episode from the office where Michael
Scott offered to pay tax yeah and then
he's like actually I don't have this
money yeah so what happens now is the
restaurant is out that money because
they gave it to her already ah but now
that three thousand dollar value is you
know he ends up freezing it and so the
restaurant is suing him
wow well isn't it isn't that the reason
why you put it in and sign your name
yeah because like it's basically a
contract a mini contract on a mini piece
of paper you said that but he could be
one to argue I didn't put those extrases
oh is he arguing that they don't know
yet what he's really gonna say how's it
lined up too like if it says you want to
see it is the three if the three is past
the one
you know what I mean then that's like
that's three thousand I was wrong there
is a comma and it's in the right spot oh
dude yeah and he added it up 3013. oh
he added it
oh Mariana well Mariana got paid wait
this was at KFC wait what yeah I thought
it was like no no no no
that's another that's another link tip
at KFC no that's what it said on the top
I'm like I've never tipped that KFC
Boba and it's like can you give me 15
tip yeah you're talking about the iPad
swimming like just like just uh fill
this out for me will you I know that's
and they're just looking directly I put
zero you did you have to do a few clicks
to get their [ __ ] face too yeah but
sometimes I feel generous and then what
does that mean 25 nice 25 25 oh do you
dispute it with your bank later no my
tip decisions is usually all across the
board if they're just chill it's 18
percent
if I like them 25 if I feel like I want
to do a sexual favor to them but I'm not
sure 3 000. I give them 100 percent
100 too yeah so you X2 your bill so like
let's say no no no so like that's the
sentiment
I'm not gonna suck them off you know I
don't oh I don't know I don't really
want to do it with them you know but I
feel like that's how grateful I am
so I'm so grateful I would do any sexual
favor for you not because of my pleasure
you might be an old man or old lady but
that's the kind of feeling I want to
give to you the intensity so let me do
it legally through tipping it's a
hypothetical so let me give you legal
sexual favors through the feeling of
tipping monetary value yeah yeah God so
you could go elsewhere and get it but
I'm not gonna tell you to do it because
it's illegal you know so so if you're
paying for a lap dance
ish but I got one already so I'm paying
for the thank you you're paying it
forward I gotta I I might have gotta I
might have had a flat mouth lap dance I
might have had a great service lap dance
whatever it is figuratively right I'm
just like writing it down and saying
like because the food's really good it
dance in his mouth yeah oh I had a mouth
right yeah yeah so I had a happy ending
is what I'm trying to say they gave me a
good happy ending well here is Marina
Lam Mariana Lambert the one you would be
mouth lap dancing if she hated you yeah
a great server [ __ ] up dude trying to
pull money back that's [ __ ] up
she got paid she did get paid but but he
tried taking it back he tried taking
back so now the restaurant is in a you
know that's not good for them because
they basically just gave her 3 000 of
their own money they need it they need
that you quit peace I'm not getting them
back she's not part of the lawsuit now
it's just between this dude and the
restaurant so she's off with money
they kick back with a
gift for her
and the Russia yeah so him I'd feel so
would you feel like giving it back until
they get it
what would you do
I know you said you're gonna quit but
like Diet guilty conscious I'm proud
I don't sue him I'd probably uh oh you
don't want him or you can sue the guy
too I'll have a phone call with him
double lawsuit I'll be like we could
sell this out of court all right I'd
give it back and then sue the restaurant
because I could probably get more money
from that than the 3 000. so even though
what he did technically uh you know in
some ways you can just dispute your own
payment and the bank kind of doesn't
really care yeah if it's like whatever
here go ahead right and even though
that's kind of like a gray area legal
thing to do is he's still in the wrong
for this or is it kind of like Hey
That's the Law he was able to I mean
it's morally wrong because he did it in
the name of Jesus and Navi regrets it in
the name of Jesus yeah I think in this
situation he's put the comma he [ __ ]
did the math he [ __ ] signed his name
like [ __ ] dude you need to man
the [ __ ] up it's a contract right so if
you bought a house you signed it and you
don't want to pay for it anymore okay
you still
you still owe the money right yeah and
to me when I see a receipt that's
basically the same [ __ ] you're agreeing
to pay that amount it says on the
receipt for gratuity reasons I think
gratuity is an agreement also like it's
an agreement to pay so so because of
that it's like you can't say hey I'm
going to pay pay it and then regret it
later I mean well you could regret it
but you can't take it back yeah you know
because to me that's a violation of what
your contract and word was or and he
signed it that's playing checkers and
your hands came off the piece man yeah
you can't do that you can't be like
never mind oh wait no your hand came off
the bees bro you let go that's that's
your final move that's your final move
bro it's in his handwriting too he's
around that one three comma zero zero
zero Ben did the math I don't know what
he's gonna say in court I think the only
time it kind of is okay is when you're
drunk
oh and be like oh I was drunk I wasn't
in the right state of mind it was a
mistake
13 drink with so much
they're like how did I spend this much
okay well here's a question how come
when the bank accidentally gives you too
much money it's illegal to keep it
because they're [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] the
bags bro because you don't know who's
signing it's just machines
I think that's that's fair because it
wasn't an agreement and it wasn't
supposed it's an accident right so like
he didn't accidentally write 3 000 and
sign it and and do the math and in the
total and then accidentally give it to
her yeah
and it depends on this motherfucker's
victory dance too let's say he was drunk
right and then you have the [ __ ]
surveillance camera that's right [ __ ]
three thousand dollars I'm a baller
right and he leaves like this and
afterwards
he walks out ah bro if you did a victory
dance like that you got to commit to it
it's gonna be all hard one day and the
next day
okay well here's here's another thing uh
let's talk about Degrees of Separation
let's say somebody stole a bike sells
the bike to B sells that bike to C to d
e f gets to you
a goes to you and says that's a stolen
bike do you give it back
you keep it I would be like if I give it
back it's a favor to you
but I don't I don't owe you anything
because I don't even know I got it from
this guy
and I got it from her it's happened to
all be in the same room
we're just passing the bike around yeah
because you know like when people Pawn
stolen goods now the pawn shop has to
look up the cereal to not sell the
camera that you jacked because
eventually it can be traced and that
person will have to give it back yeah
yeah because the way that it works is it
doesn't matter how many hands it turns
yeah it just has to go to the rightful
owner that it got stolen from but if it
keeps getting stolen who's the rightful
owner true so but and that's the story
of America what if you steal it back
what if the original owner steals it
back I've seen the ability for crime or
is it his are you trying to create a
Time Paradox with the [ __ ] Universe
chill dude that's what happened to O.J
Simpson he stole his memorabilia got he
lost his member and he went and stole it
and that's why he ended up in prison but
he was like that's my Heisman Trophy oh
foreign